well there's a guy on the line right now
that just got married to a very gorgeous
woman who is also very talented in her
own right on the phone now my
quarterback from the Seattle Seahawks
Russell Wilson Russell I mean I'm just
upset today did Dan well he still was on
the show you know he found a way on the
show he called in and he was saying that
Pierre McGuire was able to spot a Zika
mosquito above his head and saved his
life
we're still questioning whether Pierre
actually knew it was the Zika mosquito
but we digress first of all we will get
into your professional life but
personally because of course you know I
also cover entertainment I had to find
out you got married by reading a
voiceover in the vo booth and I was very
upset because I mean where's my invite
to the wedding that was one heck of a
wedding you had yeah it was a good
wedding was far away after sir
oh is that that's why I didn't invite ya
I'm very busy was the wedding obviously
you guys had to work because you both
have very very busy schedules was that
something that was planned or you kind
of mean it didn't look like you just
threw it together it looked like a fairy
tale wedding but how much went into the
scheduling of that one went to a really
good wedding planner Mindy Weiss she
helped us big-time and oh yeah time it
Wendy was the toughest part was was
getting Earth Wind & Fire there just
making sure that they could do it so we
wanted Earth Wind & Fire to play so they
rocked a night out and so the
festivities kept going till you know
5:30 in the morning the funniest part is
that my mom was still up in the in the
little wine cellar area where we have an
after-party she was still up to about 6
o'clock in the morning that was probably
the best part of the whole night I loved
that I didn't even get my parents an
invite to my first wedding and you have
Earth Wind & Fire I'm impressed but
that's how you roll now big time but no
a huge congratulations they look
absolutely beautiful so we send our best
to you and the
is alright let's talk about turn our
Thank You field for a second of course
you saw that that Hall of Fame game last
night was cancelled players safety your
thoughts well I think it's important
especially when it comes to a you know
preseason game in terms of not brisk in
those guys health and all that I think
it was a great job by the end I felt you
know canceling that game if it was going
to be a hazard to those guys and you
know potential you know problem for
those guys so you know the whole the
whole Hall of Fame game though I think
the importance of that of that week more
so is for the in the Hall of Famers
that's a special special week and
there's so many great Hall of Famers you
know being recognized you know this
weekend that's a special time for those
guys absolutely I'm speaking to the Hall
of Fame as you're watching those things
I know you always set very high goals
for yourself do you even think that far
in advance about wanting to end up in
the hollers that sort of just uh you
know one thing at a time what I'd be
lying have you lying to you if I said I
didn't you know ever every more I wake
up you know I I want to be I want to be
one of the greats to play the game
that's just kind of my mentality I don't
shy away from from greatness but it
takes a lot of hard working I got a long
ways to go I got a lot more years to go
a lot more plane to do so I just take
one game at a time one day at a time and
and you know it's important to me to
just continue to win games that that's
the most important stat of playing
quarterback yeah you've done a lot in a
very short time in the NFL when you
think back we were talking about
different memories of things what was
that moment of course because you you
were battling it out with Matt Flynn for
that starting job in Seattle and did you
remember that moment when Pete Carroll
told you that the job was yours I do I
do actually I was in the locker room and
uh and coach had one of the one of the
equipment guys come get me and I'm going
up to top this desease I don't know he's
outside he's outside of it okay so I go
outside and it was after my third
preseason game we I started that
precinct game when we played the Kansas
City Chiefs and so I go outside and
coaches as a basketball hoop we always
have it you know you know Coach Carroll
he's always shooting basketball he's
always you know trying to do that that
that whole thing he thinks he's you know
Steph Curry or
but uh so anyways I go outside play
one-on-one I'm like this is what you
wanna be out here for and he goes no no
I just wanna I just wanna I just want to
take you on one-on-one real quick so
anyways you know he drains and three
from outside and like no what I really
want to talk to you about is I want to
let you know that you're gonna be our
starting quarterback the Seattle
Seahawks you're gonna be our next
franchise quarterback and cruising
yourself and the hard work that you put
into it you know meanwhile I'm still I'm
still thinking about my dad and just all
the you know all the hard work that I
put into to this this opportunity you
know and dreams come true when you
capitalize on opportunities opportunity
that's just the truth
so I'm grateful and I'll never forget
that day
definitely a special moment and of
course knowing how proud your dad would
have been in that moment for sure for
you when we were talking about player
safety preseason stuff we just had a
Antonio on the line which real quickly I
know you guys work together in the
offseason correct yeah he's a beast out
there on the field name right this guy
wears you know 10-pound weight is
weighted vest you know on his chest the
worst you know eight pounds on his leg
you're on in 30 routes and then takes it
off and runs another ten so he's he's a
special special player and he's gonna be
a hall-of-famer for sure and the way he
works and he loves the game he's a great
football player you've got a ton of
talent around you but what makes Antonio
so good well I think it just his work
ethic you know he attacks the football I
loves playing the games go he's got a
smile on his face and he makes these
other guys around them better so you
know and so it's it's fun to watch him
play and to work out with him this
offseason yeah I got a lot of those guys
on my team too so it's always uh it's
always good when you surround yourself
around great players and those have a
guys most other guys like Antonio Brown
you know Doug bottoms of the world you
know Tyler Lockett Jermaine Kearse those
guys those guys make make life easy for
you you know and I'm excited about
getting Jimmy Graham back ya have that
guy back you know out there on the field
and comments were all he just got
cleared yesterday yeah the public you
know all those all those all those guys
have similarities you know it's the work
ethic the the the mindset you know
the players you want to be around
Russell Wilson Seattle Seahawk
quarterback of course I'm biased because
I'm from Seattle but a lot of headlines
and my dad's a die-hard Seahawks fan as
everybody is in Seattle you can't walk
down the street without getting attacked
up there but a lot of the question a
narrative over the last couple years
Russell have been this offensive line
you know a lot of different moving parts
you draft defensive guys you turn them
into offensive linemen what what are the
question marks if any or sort of what is
your response to people that say there
are still question marks about the line
well these guys are ready to go they're
gonna be ready to go I mean Justin
Britt's been working at center on
Patrick Lewis as a guy who's been
working at Center and he a lot been
played a lot of games with and won a lot
of games with as well so you know in
terms of being Calma I'll call them
there and Trust and those guys up front
you know I completely I can probably
trust those guys and and then in sense
of you know what we're gonna do you know
it's all the work all the work and I
think he put practice I think these guys
are ready to go they're all in sync this
is a group of guys that want to be the
best that want to do whatever it takes
and we just signed jari heaven too as
well
it was you know all prototype players
and all pro several years in a row and
Pro Bowl player so we're glad that we
have him too and his experience and what
he brings to the table and all the
knowledge that he brings and his work
ethic and his professionalism that's
really going to transfer over so you
know it's not just up to alignment up to
everybody it's up to everybody to do
their part and that's what makes this
game the game of football the greatest
game there is and it's a game that you
decided to play you of course we're also
drafted you could have played baseball
if you wanted to so you're a tremendous
athlete so in the spirit of the Olympics
Russell we are asking different guess
what Olympic sport they would compete in
so what would be your sport of choice oh
man I want to go in last now I think
it's uh is like karate or judo and it
only lasts like a minute it was great so
I think I said judo if not judo you know
I probably hop in the water with with
Michael Phelps yeah
just just get in my it is all the gold
medals would have gone to me no they
would have drowned you 1940 gold medal
at last count it is pretty cool to watch
somebody that is the best at their
respective sport I know you don't like
this but I'm gonna do it
Seahawks make it to the Super Bowl if
fill in the blank oh man if we win our
playoff games good answer we will leave
it right there Russell congratulations
on everything for personally and
professionally you are a class act we
appreciate the time will tell Dan you
said hi oh thank you Oh Dan that you're
a little bit better than here no we'll
make sure we save that I'll have that on
the loop when he returns from Rio
Russell we appreciate the time for you
so much the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience